the idea being a man has a changed so
dramatically right but particularly I
think not just the responsibilities of
being a father which has always been you
know not to get all khalil gibran like
these children are unknown to us and
we're supposed to make sure that we take
care of them and and were these stewards
of these human beings male roles which
is something I you know my wife and I
have written about in the show because
the concept of a father today is
dramatically different I mean obviously
it's different in every family culture
but it's different from a generation ago
and the idea of what a father's
responsibility whether it's co-parenting
whether it's staying home dad or just
someone that does lip service to the
idea of sharing responsibility is so
different from 1910 and you know like
the you know I have this joke where it's
like and then you go back to cavemen and
they're literally eating their children
I think it's it's perspective on how we
treat women right that is the beginning
and the ending of it we are animals I
start from that premise and we choose to
not behave like animals and that's you
know a pretty guiding force through
humanity whether it it gets completely
out of control or just panting like a
dog when a attractive woman walks by you
know I even look at lake pornography and
all this stuff where it's
yeah you know it's like look I love
naked women I really do but I also know
that I'm a visual human being and and I
can't you know I can't consume images of
naked women and not have that influence
how I view other women I mean that's my
personal opinion I don't so like it's
like my sexual desires are are very
valid and real but if I if I you know
followed through on every sexual desire
first of all I'd have a thousand
children no but I think then that's not
how you that's not how you get I
wouldn't feel very good dear i mean when
i look at my young sons I think that
look I know that we love in like the
normalization of porn and I'm not you
know it's like to each their own right
but I don't think that I want my son's
consuming pornography I want my son's to
look at an advertisement and say that is
a beautiful woman but she's being
objectified and i do want even beyond
that i personally think that in the
united states we give credit and
appreciate attractive people too much
and so i think that i want to instill
that i mean i think a lot of parents
desperately want to have nerdy children
so but i don't know i want my kids to be
my son's to be better men than me but I
think also you know it's different path
to getting there I mean look I'm
Catholic you're gonna think I'm crazy
but I think that's an important tool
also but I also think that you know
understanding the logic and science
behind it is vital but culturally it's
interesting I saw a clip of match game
which was a show a game show when I was
growing up from the mid 70s 80s I don't
know and the beginning of the show it
was just filled with the host more or
less sexually harassing the female
contestants and it was not malicious and
that man did not know he was doing it
and maybe those women didn't feel icky
but from our standards today it was
ridiculous I mean I also feel like to
discredit everything I've said I also
think that I don't want us to get to the
point where there isn't passion right
you know when I met my wife and we went
on our first date you know I
aggressively kissed or not in a
monstrous way but even hearing myself
describe it I don't know if we could do
that today and i'm sure i could have
because there's there's a communication
that's unspoken right when you're
courting someone but courting like it's
the 1800s like you're writing a horse to
meet them but there is something about
there's rules but there's also what's so
great about relationships is that
tingling feeling when the chemistry that
we can't articulate works
you